in just one week you will see the game
stations most incredible battle royale
yet in guns of Icarus online starring
Captain totalbiscuit tricking
peanutbutter gamer and angry Joe versus
captain maximilian valentine jesse cox
captain of the sky dodger try and me
what will you see
well there's gonna be a lot of this and
some of this and look at this and boom
bang ii everything gonna explode
and confirm bang so if this is our ship
and this is their ship it's gonna be
like fighting fighting slow so be there
May 10th on the game station and also
click the link in the description below
to support the guns of Icarus
Kickstarter to raise money for adventure
mode to give yourself a whole world to
explore my name is markiplier and I will
see you at the battle royale bye bye
[Music]